today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter baby today's guests are two
comedians who have just broken back into
performing live stand-up comedy that's
right this weekend they were in Oklahoma
City and Salt Lake City and and I'm just
really curious as to what their what
their experience was like we have
comedian Brad Williams and comedian Jeff
die
[Music]
because you're definitely I remember the
first time I ever met you Brad it was
like I was at USC I don't know what I
was doing not learning I was there this
is like an outsider and uh yeah and you
came up on a motorbike yeah like a small
motorbike yeah and I'd never seen
anything like this like you know where I
was growing up they had one man who was
kind of a smaller man that did mechanic
work you know exam and he uh yeah oh
yeah I remember they open the hood put
him under there little close the hood
and he fix it while people were driving
No so just oh he would be in there like
he would hide he would do a lot of
hiding I'm gonna hide you know which I
think you know I don't know Vantage yeah
but um but yeah man I remember anything
you pulled up at a pretty good clip of
feet and I was like oh my god I'm in
another I like just gotten in Los
Angeles um I got another four well you
know that scare Texas show that you
mentioned like they basically every
prank involved a little person yeah
you're like oh she's afraid of teddy
bears what if we put Brad in this teddy
bear and we'll make him run around make
him act like a teddy bear at first but
then don't run around yeah that's good
and the next one's like some lab where
it's a giant rat oh yeah put Brad in a
giant rat cause Trant monsters
everything is based around a little
person but yeah the guy not got no glory
yeah and I I totally remember that
because that rate a razor scooter
released these electric scooters back in
the day at but like they had one that
was look really cheesy and then they had
one that looked like a like a West Coast
chopper yeah
now I'm like all these other kids around
USC get the class on bike I'm riding my
West Coast Choppers or scooter that's
insane I've never seen anything like it
I didn't know the laws yeah at school
because I was going there I went to us
alright yeah and I think yeah I booked
you for like a comedy show on campus or
something you must have been a legend
you were like how many thought you until
you have to see you us UFC I don't where
you went yeah I'm not good with schools
and letters yeah yeah it was a dwarf UFC
happen in a ball pit
don't start something no it was no it
was mean then there was a teacher there
okay and everyone thought I was this kid
right like some people are about yeah so
they must be related yeah everyone
thought that like that's how I got in is
like it's that oh well your dad works at
USC so that's how you got it it's like
no I got in is because they needed
something they need someone for the
pamphlet also I have a regular brain and
I'm a regular person they think there
must be something yeah yeah yeah no yeah
yeah he got in cuz he cast a spell on
the president I've always wondered like
do you like you know is it okay to talk
about being if somebody is a small
person or smaller different um but what
I'm thinking is like sometimes I'll see
like you know they have LGTBQ community
yeah but they don't factor in like but
little people don't get factored into
that well that's the LPA community oh
the people of America okay that's not
even a joke it's it's a it's yeah LP a
which was started by Billy Barty the
actor and then actually when they
started they were called midgets of
America changed it and then they changed
it so that's why yeah there it is so
that so that went yeah when they started
it was called they just killed it man
this comes on everything yeah so we so
this guy started the LPA yep
and so yeah so there's a lot of dwarves
that have boned each other because of
this man nice guys he started LPA oh
because then it's a place to meet other
people other sources baby thank you for
what you did there's without this guy we
wouldn't have all those shitty shows on
TLC which are some I really yeah we're
like we're a family of little people you
like I don't give a [ __ ] and they
literally like aren't we're just like
everyone else you're like then why am i
watching it just like everyone else then
why is this Whitewood but that won't
make you little man yeah little people
big world yeah I love them I mean the
sister was finebros why is the day i
mean when she was old it and in the tall
dudes lap like in that photo it looks
like the death is sitting in the tall
guy hate me shows i hate these kind of
shows yeah well we're fascinated about
but the shower member specifically was
they've ran a pumpkin ranch yeah and the
fact it's in my mind yeah blew my mind
that you had small people growing the
largest vets remember I see I used to do
jokes about it's a big squash and
they're just lugging around like ants
that's some like think of it like yeah
that yeah I mean there you go it would
what it would make way more sense that
they're like oh they have a strawberry
patch yeah yeah cherries makes that's
how I was gonna go um yeah there's no we
know we got pumpkins baby two marriages
with overachievers do use sometimes but
uh do you ever look at like a gay person
or a diverse person a black person maybe
a Vietnamese maybe fun question for me
to answer let's go and does it ever but
you don't talking about I just love
you're searching for words to kill okay
Filipino uh you know people like you
know but do you know what I'm talking
about unique friends I'll call tread
lightly amen
we're only white guys what we don't got
a thing what is their camaraderie
they're like if you see like if you're
walking down the street like in like a
white neighborhood and there's a black
guy and he's walking on the street is
there camaraderie if you guys see each
other kind of oh between like me and a
black guy yeah no but I will say this
there's not that instant there there
there isn't that instant camaraderie but
I do a bit about this and it's real like
I would loved how black people would
react to seeing dwarves like it
it was never different yeah it was never
just like there's a person and like it
was never that it was like oh [ __ ]
dab you up always like insanely friendly
but yet kind of insulting you know it's
like oh what up big man it's like why
would you say a big man to me that is
like what do you see a guy in wheelchair
and just be like yo legs let's go but
also just look kind of good cuz like
this black guy's been really nice to me
but also yeah I should get mad at him
for
yeah yeah and then it's been like like
there was one time it was it was back
when I was at USC at hurry man that they
do that I always found it funny I was uh
I was at USC and then I was on the
street where all the fraternities are
it's called it's called the ro it's
where all of turning Tory roads are and
I was with a few of my friends and like
a group black guys came up to me and my
buddies and just started like like
aggressively positively complimenting me
but then calling light word but like and
then like one of my friends got jealous
he's like what I'm not a and and and and
and they look at him like no like hell
no you don't you don't say you get so
there's times where you get an inward
pass I like not to say it but I get
called it right and you get to be one
yeah you're really and yeah yeah so so
there's not like now if I walk down the
street and I see another person who has
some kind of disability either they're
in a chair or an or on another dwarf
then then we give each other like a nod
like what's up okay you know the
struggle I love it so but it but that
kind of stops here it doesn't go into
like is he I always wanted like if you
see a black guy and there and like a
plate like because you know a lot of
black people feel like outliers kind of
you know in the in the US and so I was
wondering like but they don't do that
with each other that's not like black
people not like Puerto Ricans or
Vietnamese or like you know I'm saying
no I don't think that they do that that
doesn't cross borders like lesbians
aren't like what's up like this has been
three white guys discuss race just
wondering I don't know you're the
closest thing we have to a black guy
right now you know I'm saying not enough
you know it'd be ass for ya wait so when
you're in Texas with guys that you went
to like high school with and stuff and
you guys are just it's just you guys
back home yeah do you guys give each
other n-word passes oh it's a good point
I mean people use it a lot more I don't
think anybody let's give it to each
other I think people definitely maybe
stole a pack
yeah look what I got these passes we can
use while we're at home tonight just
does
I think people somebody definitely stole
a packet of passes from the principal's
oh man like I just remember Ralphie May
would always just say it and not care
like you would say it because he was at
a wait I feel like he was like a kind of
a weight you know like a like he had
that like he had a theater I never heard
how he got away with it if you get to a
certain level of something where it's
like you feel like maybe like you're an
outcast or something they always go on
from Chattanooga so I can say it's AG
I've been to Chattanooga it's like the
most segregated place in the world dude
he used to say here black bear he did
yeah he say I'm the number-one chata
and finish it all yeah that's
Chattanooga's definitely a little racist
anyway it's so segregated and if he's a
big fat white guy he was probably in the
white side I think it's my name I don't
mean just by name you know well I give
your a like if your high schools like
the new girls like oh look this up
there's got a sound there's a um it's a
high school or a college in Oklahoma
where like their mascot is like the
fightin midgets really yeah and like
everyone there so mice there was one in
Illinois actually I know what kid that I
think went to a school in the the [ __ ]
was a mascot of fighting they just
manage its mascot Dickinson high South
Dakota Oh South Dakota North Dakota
there it is dick is changeable in North
Dakota
oh no they change it from the midgets to
the mustangs hmm I don't know if I like
that the little people of America have
more clout than all of the Native
Americans because like Redskins they're
just like we're not changing the man
yeah yeah yeah win fact on opening day
we're gonna bring out some Native
Americans will pay him some money put
them in Chiefs jerseys or whatever yeah
yeah and say no we're cool with it
before they even consider changing it
right we will have will have chief wahoo
yeah it was just a white guy who's like
riding a horse out there I love chili
I'm a big fan of chief wahoo
you know the guy no I don't know the guy
but I'm saying like the Indians you know
why they're called the Indians I'm gonna
nerd out I love baseball
cuz it's from Indiana nope no they were
they were called the Cleveland spiders
and then they get they had like the
first ever Native American on the
baseball team oh wow and then one and
then they got an a they got like a
second Native American and they were
only they were the only team to have
like two Native Americans and so one of
the guys on the Cleveland Indians on the
Cleveland spiders the time goes man we
should start calling ourselves the
Cleveland Indians he's like basically
razzing his teammates yeah and they were
like yeah it'd make us look super
progressive like it'll be good
so they so they literally started
calling them the Cleveland Indians they
changed the team name and the original
chief wahoo was actually he looked a
little less racist he could kind of look
like one of these Simpsons guys he was
like a yellow faced chief wahoo and
that's the things Judd Apatow is that
great joke they did on The Tonight Show
there's like any drawing of a Jewish
person is inherently anti-semitic
yeah because like if I hand you papers
to draw Jewish person in you hand it
back to me it's gonna look pretty
offensive right because you're trying to
draw the attributes of the person same
thing up with this they said draw an
Indian and the cartoonist here screw it
all down you can see that you yeah their
original chief while he was kind of
yellow and then they had to like redo it
because Native Americans and people were
very upset but look at the new one the
new one that just gave them veneers made
him red yeah chief whoa and also chief
wahoo is supposed to mean like
celebrating Indians like wahoo we're
celebrating so it's all well-intentioned
I say like all the Indian stuff is
pretty well intentioned it just amazes
me that they changed the name to the
Cleveland Indians after they had two
Indian players like you imagine is but
that's kind of nice though when you
think about it they thought they were
doing it like a funny cool thing yeah
but like just imagine if all teams did
that like when Jackie rock on the
Dodgers like well we're not the Dodgers
anymore were that then you say sometimes
Jackie
they used to be Atlanta crackers and
that was a Negro Leagues team really in
the Atlantic crackers that's hilarious
oh they were called the Atlanta black
crackers or the black crackers we met
because they were kind of saying like
we're like our team of white boys I
don't know if that's how that worked but
they were the ago the Atlanta crackers
played first in the Southern Association
game baseball 1902 yeah and I don't know
if I
why they were called that but I think
the origins of team name is unknown but
there was a if you go to the Negro
League museum we actually rate as
awesome the Jazz museum not even have
time for Jazz museum because I just was
patronizing we did we're in Cleveland no
the Negro League museum is in Kansas
City yeah it is awesome yeah and I
stayed over there so much because I just
love baseball so much and they were like
they thought I was mocking them they're
like nobody likes it this much like this
guy's been in there for like six hours
like watched avid I read everything yeah
all this crap but but yet they were
called the Atlanta the Atlantic crackers
and I think that they were doing that as
like a like a nephew to the white League
like alright well goes with the crackers
yeah when I saw that high school was
called the fightin midgets I'm like I
want a t-shirt like I don't want you to
shut down what the intentions are good I
think that's how I measure it not
everyone imagines it that way that's
right that it's like you're naming your
school the fightin midgets that means
you think that the [ __ ] is
intimidating powerful yeah you don't
mean that means it's like oh you're a
tiger [ __ ] you
we're the midgets and when in real life
we would be a snack but they're like no
well what's worse being ignored and
acted like you're not a thing yes or
being acknowledged and and dealing with
whatever kind of uncomfortability of
that difference is does that make sense
no totally and and cuz the worst thing
you could do to anyone who is
quote-unquote different is ignore that
right and ignore ignore difference yeah
it like if I see a guy it happened this
weekend uh-oh
okay this so I did shows in Oklahoma
City this weekend and right in the front
row a female dwarf set right in the
front road she's right in it's just it
was like okay I have to mention this I
can't not talk about the fact there's a
dwarf right there in the front row and I
asked her what she did for a living and
no [ __ ] she goes I'm a psychologist
I go and I'd start laughing and
everyone's like why are you laughing
I go cuz she's a shrink and I'm like
come on like you've got a perfectly she
loved it she loved it and and that
moment would have never happened sure if
I were to just ignore like oh I don't
see another
right in my audit it's a big Tiffany no
one's ever called me that big girl but I
want to live my life is like I I'm I'm
friends with lots of different people
walks of life I don't just blanketly
think I'm a good person and not knowing
how many people are like these we gotta
fight for these trans rights I'm like
named five of your trans friends and
I've never liked meta trans yeah exactly
shut the hell up
yeah cookie like that date it's all it's
hectic man it's hectic too like yeah I
think it met but naturally you feel a
certain way like naturally you kind of
know how to behave yeah you know I feel
like and then you can tell if somebody
else is upset yeah you know oh okay that
was bad yeah that was too much and then
you apologize I think your honor him
like questions I mean you guys probably
friends for a long time but you asking
questions like hey is it okay if I just
ask you and that's why I think way more
respectful and having someone and just
completely like my buddies my buddy
Nico's his son has like like kind of a
birth defect in his hands so he's like
Spock yeah kind of turtle you know he's
got like three and oh like Ryan eemiller
kinda what do you mean like iLike I just
asked what happened yeah and he was
happy to talk about and we'd have to be
this like weird like eight what you know
yeah yeah you I think that's how you
should address those things yeah it's
time so I do usually like if I'll see
somebody that's missing a limb or
something I'll just I ask him hey what
happened you know how do you lose your
leg what happened your leg I'm just
trying to get a Starbucks oh just tell
me whatever
yeah come what happened in that leg you
only sign it there like it's not a cast
it's a piece of titanium you know like
well this is summer
he's like the over yeah get away from me
with that marks Allah never change I
want to talk I'm sitting with Brad
Williams and Jeff died both comedians
allegedly the road dogs and you guys I
feel like we're the both of the first
guys who have gone and performed yeah
live comedy since this whole thing yeah
we weren't wiseguys this weekend yeah
and I was and they're there next weekend
right yeah and I was at not virtually we
flew there and flew there we did the
whole thing is so crazy how was that
Brickton comedy yeah Oklahoma City so
yeah explain to me I was at wise guys in
Salt Lake City
yeah just blaming me why it's crazy well
I guess me my first I guess like
I don't know I don't have any fear of
like people coming to the event I didn't
even need my thoughts anyway I never
thought about that I had thoughts about
like as a comedian being on stage since
there's gonna be less people in the
audience would I feel like bummed out
what I feel like this isn't the same
like what I feel like and then I started
thinking from a business standpoint like
okay well is this business even gonna
make enough money like are these
waitresses gonna make enough money
tonight like I'll tell you who didn't
make enough money the comedian
yeah they've got a reason to go hey man
we have a limited audience yeah yeah so
you know it's only we have to cap them
out at a hundred I can't like work a
bonus deal or anything like that so that
was the waitress made great money they
did yeah yes because everyone's
audiences on and you guys will both know
this and maybe any one that listens that
isn't a commune you might not know but
audiences are famously and more so than
ever now that podcasts blown up people
people didn't use to know comedians they
just went to the Improv and they did
maybe hope to be a famous person and all
the other communities maybe like this is
great I would say in the last eight
years I've witnessed with the success of
you and Segura and basically everyone
that's on this wall right is now people
if they haven't seen you before they're
like who's this guy I've never heard of
him and then the vibe shifts to this
weird like make me laugh [ __ ] like
that's the vibe where I'm unfunny til
proven funny and then it kind of is like
oh he is funny and I have never even
heard of him cuz I listen to all the
podcasts I'm shocked that someone is
funny but I don't know right where is
that totally changed yeah this weekend
dude people were so generous like one
dude tipped our server like 200 bucks
all these people were gushing to me like
oh my god thank you sir it was they were
just so happy yeah I was crushing on
like throwaway lines like so is very
generous yeah did you feel um what were
some of you guys as fears going into it
before we even talked about what the
weekend with the weekends were like like
did you have any like just our thoughts
even just thoughts yeah I wasn't worried
about the shows and in terms of like you
look out in the audience and sounds
different because it's at a third
capacity or a half capacity or whatever
it is my philosophy is okay or I could
stay home and there's no show there's no
one laughs there's nothing there's
nothing you know so and yeah you're not
going to just flip flip a switch and we
all come back and it's exactly the way
it was
we gotta acclimate gradually get into it
and you know kind of test the waters a
little bit and then if it's good then
we'll move them up to the next level I
was more worried about the travel than
anything that and it was for me like the
worst part for me wasn't the shows I
love the shows that the audience's much
like you said were great they were so
starved for content they want to go out
they wanted to have fun but traveling
that was weird because you had to wear
the masks the whole time which when you
go to the grocery store it's like okay
it's an hour but when you're flying when
I'm flying to Oklahoma City that's six
hours we don't realize how many actually
try to drinks yeah yeah that's six hours
of wearing a mask and then like my ears
are hurting you know you know yeah and
like they're not they're not serving
food on the plane so you got it like if
it's a long flight you're like okay I
got a snack up before I get on and we're
the seat spaced-out and your flights
more without that Southwest was American
Airlines and not give it you two you're
too famous to fly south this guy's
flying South 198 bucks hey you got it so
I flew from LAX to Salt Lake City and so
excited to Seattle Seattle to LAX
because they cancel always like legs of
flight right right right on your trip
home there was nobody in the airports
nobody on my flight that was kind of
eerie but that's pretty safe I mean like
if I see no people I'm not afraid yeah
also I will say and I know this is gonna
annoy all the liberal New York comedians
that I'm gonna say this but I dealt with
the pretty like selfishly mm-hmm like I
was like I'm not afraid I want to go
tell jokes I'm wearing the mask out of
respect for others if you want to come
hug me I don't give a [ __ ] like I'm so
well and also like okay like right like
for you personally you're in that group
that according to the science it's like
you should be fine like you're you don't
have an immune problem you're a healthy
guy you got a big dick like like you
like you I will say the people that come
to my shows yeah obviously seem to not
care either right and I don't so if they
get me sicker I get them sick [ __ ] them
yeah they come out yeah that came out
yeah and so it's like I'm not hurting
Graham Graham she's at home right I'm
and I know that that's a selfish take
and I'm admitting that I'm selfish
because I just want to get back to
comedy so
bed yeah and I'm so tired of being at my
house with my dog I tried to do one of
those virtual shows had a great time but
it wasn't the same yeah and so I need to
I needed it I needed to like my I need
my hotel rooms I need to flirt with
girls I need to tell jokes I needed some
sort of semblance of what I'm used to
whenever you got to the club like did
you feel like where did they seem really
really excited to like be back in
business like yeah they were stoked and
the waitstaff was stoked because they
had a job you know that's like people
were happy man yeah yeah it's I mean
I'll respect anyone's wishes if they
want to stay home if they want to go out
whatever but like I understand when you
say oh all the restaurants are closed
there's some people there that just okay
they can't they can't hunker down for
3-4 months and then be fine like their
rent is dude they got the guy they gotta
buy food they got to do all these things
like so I respect that if they if
they're like no I have to go work so and
also we weren't out of the beach like
yeah like laying on each other and
sweating and stuff well I was at a
comedy club in and that literally like
everybody that came in had to keep the
temperature taken yeah okay
sanitized really had to wear masks to
come in they had to wear their masks on
the way out when they get sat at their
table the tables are six feet apart
right there's no party larger than four
mm-hmm each comic had their own separate
microphone that were sanitized in
between the show so I mean there's a
safe way to do this do you bring your
mic from you didn't jokingly brought up
mic from home to do like gag that Isis
gag where there's gonna be breath
there's gonna be bad sorry if you see me
at the store and then you see me do it
again in the improv like I just saw does
it yeah so the joke is like I would come
out I did this way before the quarantine
I would come out and I would like look
like I was like disgusted with like the
microphone and I would like take it out
and then put it on the table and then
I'd pull out like gold microphone out of
my back pocket and just act like and
then and then everyone like laugh cuz
they were like so confused by me doing
the first part right and then I'd like
yeah you know they don't clean those
things and it just makes me look like
this elitist kind of guy like that the
problem with that bit is it's hilarious
if I'm following like that you know drew
that stuttering guy
I'm following you know Theo or something
but if I'm following like Miss Pat and I
just come out I'm like what the hell was
that man yeah just do like a racist like
so that's why yeah I stopped doing it I
bet Billy doesn't you're like you know
those people yeah you know those people
that aren't welcome at the VFW you know
what I'm talking about and I'm so dumb
that I didn't put that together I was
just like why did nobody laughs this
time it looks like an and so I stopped
doing it but then as Jamar neighbors
went on before you so I brought that
same mic and did the same gag each show
for this oh that's fun yeah because
there was four mics we're all asked to
take one of those mics down and I'm
gonna pretend like they didn't leave me
a mic and I'm just gonna have to like do
the gag that I brought my own yeah and
that's the thing is like you said like
there's there's precautions that you
could take so it's definitely like it's
not yes the say the safest thing would
be to just stay in your homes and throw
a blanket over you and never leave your
house yeah that's the safest thing but
there are there are ways to do these
shows that it's like okay yeah take take
temperatures stay spread apart and no no
one was sat at a table with someone they
didn't know so like wow it's so it's
like yeah if you came in the same car
together you sat at the same and I had a
virus I feel fine Hirono harris models
would be cool if they had like a group
of men or women that have it that are
fine for 10 yeah like some sores on us
they just like act like I don't know who
would be what comedians of you I've
always Jeff's only like kind of you what
maybe D'Elia gets factored and I think
by his confidence Oh for like handsome
good-looking male commotion tones met
Kevin Hart John Mulaney Lachlan Peterson
Lachlan no one's better
what's that Lachlan Patterson Patterson
sorry I've named oh no one's better
looking than Lachlan Patterson that
generic like not generic but there's the
this there's that old ideology like he's
too good-looking to be a community or
something yeah if you look at like how
many like there's tons of good-looking
comedians yeah there yeah they Richard
Pryor I guess was kind of handsome
oh good Eddie Murphy Oh like y'all okay
God well but it's like I'm an Avery
Seinfeld
not ugly Johnny Carson was handsome yeah
cuz you all cuz you also have to factor
in Letterman's but he's we're looking at
it from the scope of Los Angeles like oh
well I'm in LA six or seven but yeah but
then you go out to South Dakota to
perform for the fighting midgets and
you're like oh I'm a nine exactly this
is awesome good look at Kristen Lee is a
good like there's like think about as a
handsome dude what's the guy I don't
know what he's talking about dude he
could be a comedian he could be working
for postman yeah good night good-looking
guy but nobody would ever go here too
good-looking to do a comedy cuz that's a
black guy so they're just gonna go you
know that's his thing's a black guy you
can't can't say that he's too handsome
yeah you spelled jack wrong Jack Jack
he's supposed to Jay but they found it
though
okay Google's like we know what you mean
white guy but that's the thing is like
like why isn't one Kevin Hartz hands and
they're not like he's too good-looking
for comedy like well it's short and he's
a black guy let him it's like what he's
a really black sighs you get a black
pass handsome you had to grow a mullet
for God's sakes everyone's going that
guy's too good-looking oh you know I
felt hoorah
so I'm comfortable without long hair
really oh dude
once I grew my hair long mmm I never now
couldn't even imagine it being short
again I don't know I don't know I just
felt so exposed before if you never grow
it cuz yeah happened I saw pictures of
myself I said man I never had long hair
I'm never gonna have it in my whole life
I guess yeah and so then I grew it out
and I was like oh wow dude I love this
is what I was supposed to have you look
like some [ __ ] kept taking me to get
my hair cut my mother miss Bobby dude
this lady named Miss Bobby I thought she
was a man forever because of her name
but she wasn't it was just she was like
an IMD and they used to call Bo be bie
and she used to cut my hair for [ __ ]
four dollars dude miss Bobby miss Bobby
shoutout to that dude and I miss Bobby
she had scissors that was her basically
her her that's how she got the job he
cut one you figured like [ __ ] no mirrors
in the whole place where you cut it so
what else at the place I didn't think
about the mics so the microphones on
stage because I'm just trying to think
like yeah to me it did it feel like you
guys were
like you guys feel like holy [ __ ] like I
didn't think I was until I got back I
posted I thought you didn't post yours I
post on Instagram I posted all mine on
all on all the stuff just say hey I'm
out comedy's back let's do this come to
the shows let's have a good time blah
blah yeah and I must have gotten and I'm
not exaggerating probably 40 people 40
comics either text or call to the next
day looking for work looking at the same
was that like oh yeah yeah every - oh
yeah I've never any Letterman's never
called my phone in my life yeah like
will do snotty text back and forth like
there I'm like stoned at a hotel and
Annie Letterman yeah she's great to sext
with even though neither one y'all's
gonna hook up with each other no joke
and he's great for that know that she
just loves like conversation so you're
like sexy yeah I was bad on the phone
with her I was like kind of like I
didn't expect anyone to call I don't
know is I should have answered yeah I
got I got a few comics calling me too
and it's like it's like you guys know
that it's just like it's a comedy right
same like it was it was the same
it was the same yeah there's a few less
people I was more bummed that like in
between shows or during the daytime I
couldn't walk around like do things in
the city I did do those bummed about
that I did that but it was just the same
as kind of California like where you I
walked like a coffee shop I was able to
have coffee there mm-hmm
I like set like this park there was a
bar that had like an open patio you
could sit on there you go so that was
kind of nice and I was giddy I wouldn't
shut up I was sitting with two friends
yeah and I just like was motormouth
because I was so excited to be back like
in the sunshine I've had it with like a
cold if you like food and I was like
being able to just do yeah cuz I've been
in my house man yeah yeah and you were
so you were in Oklahoma City yeah and
and that and that was rough because that
that club it's a great club it's in the
middle of this downtown area called
brick town and like I got sad walking
around during the day because it's like
there's a minor-league baseball park
right there Oklahoma City Dodgers play
and then the the Thunder stadium is
right there too and there's a big movie
theater there's a Riverwalk there's all
this stuff I'm like wow if this was all
open this with I could go to a baseball
during the day coming early see the
Thunder play see a movie like it would
have been a whole great weekend so that
so that club is gonna be fantastic once
once everything starts opening up again
it's gonna be great but that one's the
club the sanam Norwest
yeah that's that yeah yeah the same
people that do Tacoma it looked like
they packed them kind of in on yours I
saw a picture to show cuz I could say
I'm finding the stuff I was looking for
yours yeah when he told me you does it I
didn't read it
cuz I mean we talked about you going to
wise guys yeah yeah and and so I was
looking for it and I only could find
like a dude tagged you in a photo from
like the back green room area yeah yeah
yeah where the seats were yeah are you
nervous about putting it on social media
I was I put it on Instagram because
that's people that follow you that like
they like you they love you I was I
didn't put it on Twitter because I was
nervous that someone would start
retweeting it I was hoping someone would
start calling me an [ __ ] for bein
goddamn living go ahead yeah laser
talking about being you're such a hero
for staying home with your parents go
ahead come at me oh how heroic you
millionaire you have sex for two months
get a life you could don't you Nikki you
do gross your things all the time
bragging about anal sex if you're
worried about a virus like shut up yeah
wear a face mask on your behold it if
you want really take care there's some
sort of weird like here oh is it like oh
we're such heroes there is well I
noticed too that there's this thing
where I think a lot of people want you
to stay home because it gives them and I
my sentence about Nikki but just it
gives them a sense of control control
and a sense of like okay I don't have to
do anything nobody can do anything
there's the photo it keeps him in a safe
space yeah that's the one I was
referring to yeah
so that's pretty close to each other wow
that's nice man yeah well they only look
close to each other compared to where I
play it I guess well that and it's like
okay
I mean I'll tell you that from this
stage this is a weird angle because yes
it looks very close to each other but
it's like those photos of the beach were
there where they're like so-and-so's on
the beach you know all the all the
people and then if you really zoom in
you're like oh no people are separate
yeah like they're not like they're not
like throwing a towel like on top of
each other like in the NFL they always
air the game
from the side so it looks like those
linemen are right next to each other but
if there was a bird's-eye view or if
right north to south yeah there see that
there's a gap yeah yeah then guess so
yeah or like whenever you get it catch a
fish memory if you caught a fish you put
in the back of a fake truck remember and
took that picture you're like look at
this big fish and it was just some
little fish yeah dude it was great and
they all grabbed obviously do that they
they all had a great time and yeah it
was just so like I got so many messages
afterwards yeah for everyone's want to
know yeah and all my scared friends gone
uh-huh yeah and you're doing that yeah
it's almost like you guys are almost
like the Neil Armstrong and whoever the
and buzz halter and I feel like I'm
comedy I'm not even joking man it was
like I was like oh my god because I've
been taking a break from heaven guests
just having guests on the podcast it's
been really tired and so yeah but I was
like oh my god I said I just have to
know about this well and I think yeah
that's bread yeah there we go oh nice
it's a good shot I'm up there yeah
because I didn't do a meet-and-greet
afterward so I had a moment where I was
like all right everyone take take out
your phones and I'm gonna do some poses
on the stage so you can like have a
photo and post on your social media
because I don't want to do a mean greet
so I start like grabbing the mic saying
like doing stuff that I would never do
actually during my act and I thought
social distancing I'll just wave a mic
stand around my face and let's be strong
man those mic stands are compact biceps
I also want to go in and uh with Brad
Williams Brad Williams comic add rev
Williams comic was amazing funnies help
for someone so little that's the comment
what is over so much so look what do you
think a tiny person telling jokes isn't
gonna be good laughs would be one third
of they fit all the funny in that little
guy
he's tiny I didn't think I'm tiny a guy
would be funny
god I will admit my mean Greek got it
responsible that is yeah cuz you know
I'm talking a big game on stage acting
like I don't care I'm doing all these
jokes about how like I was like I didn't
get my coronavirus from some Millennials
sneezing on me new but when I heard
about it I ordered bats I ate a bat
that's what I did I want from the source
I got it right way so I'm doing all
these like and that's riling them up a
little you know and so it's riling them
up in the worst way we're like yeah [ __ ]
these masks what do we you know and
that's the worst I'm that's
irresponsible but I was just doing
County and then afterwards of the mean
grid they're like hey can we get photo
with you and I said yeah you want a mask
or no mask and they're like dude we
don't care about that and like all
touching like that it did get a little
yeah yeah you get nervous at that point
a little yeah then yeah then the guys
like starting to lick your face and
stuff they're obviously yeah yeah it's
interesting it's like it's definitely
become I think a lot of people that are
it's like you know do I
am i risking getting sick or am I just
do I think that this thing is kind of
run its course do I feel like we've done
everything that we can is like about
flattening the curve it's always kind of
two weeks you know every time they say
like Oh two weeks for this two weeks to
that I think you just got to make your
decision yeah it's like yeah I would
never judge anyone for wearing gloves
out in public and doing the mask and
like keeping it I think that's great
yeah I just if you don't want to do that
that you know like what's that one guy
God he gave us like free will yeah yeah
we love that about it we love that he
lets us do it
well like whatever this consequence is
all right yeah that's your yeah that
because that's the way that I feel a lot
of times I'm still gonna be smart and
wise I've always had I feel like decent
instincts so I'm gonna trust my
instincts yeah and and like like my
parents are both like 75 and my dad's my
dad's immune-compromised he should not
be right going out and if you're gonna
go hang out with them you shouldn't be I
should go get tested like it like if
grandma's living with you at your house
then then you have a different
responsibility all right so we're not
saying like everyone just go out but if
you're young healthy 30 30 year old 20
year old you're like I want to go just
have a little bit of fun yeah and
there's a very fond sit was a very few
times
someone was in like my bubble right to
be honest like if I look over the entire
weekend there was very few times that it
was it was even that close to me yeah
there really is actually whenever you go
to a comedy club there's not there's
really aren't a lot of times is separate
when you're in the green room with other
comics there's not a lot of times and if
you don't do meet and greet then there's
not a lot of times where you interact
like real to close with other people
really you come out on stage yeah I mean
you're almost really the safest person
in the room in a lot of ways as the
committee that was my that was my
thought and I even I even when I was
doing my show I even tried to be at the
back of the stage because I thought oh
if I talk and like I spit out and
because I've done that before where I've
been on stage and I've said something
and I and I watch the spill yeah oh yeah
that's an advice and it's like oh that's
going right yeah that guy's getting I
had one guy walk on the Friday Early
Show because we had all the microphones
out there of all three of them I guess
but I told him to strike one of them and
then I use the thing and so the other
two microphones are just behind me with
the things in and I'm saying like right
guys are we really that scared even the
people that are the most scared who
claim that they're the most scared of
this they're they're all they're all at
home going would you watch Tiger Qing
and singing just sending each other like
big black guy dick names like nobody's
really that afraid if this is the end of
the world like no one seems to really be
that scared and so the people are like
you know chairman and so I got right
we're not afraid and I just started
palming the other mics like oh love the
other comics like mics like with my bare
hands
well that's also because you're in Utah
and that basketball player Rudy a no now
Rigobert I thought it would be funny
like to do like a thing like that
also they sanitized those mics in
between and I'm the last guy so that we
on a sanitized the same artists so I
thought it's funny everyone's like I'm
gonna laugh and this dude was [ __ ]
furious he like stood up he like went to
the front what is he doing it I mean
this is the whole thing is that we were
doing this responsibly and he's doing I
was like kind of in the middle then that
guy's like yeah well and you also watch
the whole show with his mask on he had
like like the entire most people took
the mask off for the show and then they
put the mask back on yeah the whole
thing brave is that guy though think
about that like if in your head that's
where you are fear why I wanted to go to
a place yeah and you're
yeah I'm gonna rough it out yeah I'll
make myself do this yeah it's my wife's
birthday yeah and like I said if you
want if you want to stay home I'm not
gonna make fun of anyone for wanting to
stay home like to stay home it's fun but
then if someone wants to go out and be
responsible and you know it's like yeah
if you're if you're walking up to people
and strangers and spitting on them or
licking their faces okay you're kind of
a dick but yeah but if everyone's kind
of like playing their part and doing
their thing okay we can start we start
coming back to what we do what we had
before what if I'm making it sound like
just by leaving your home at any time to
do anything you're a part of the problem
like you must be some Republican crazy
person yeah thinks this virus isn't real
it's like no there's ways to go about
your life and try to earn some money and
try to like a job or try to maintain
groceries there's ways that you can go
do your life yeah oh no is a flea right
and responsibly not as what it was but
yeah I think our being responsible yeah
yeah I had someone yell at me in my
neighborhood for taking my dog for a
walk because I didn't my mask on it's
like no one no one walks toward no one
walks towards us no one does anything
I'm taking my dog for a walk like that
and and I got an I have an 80 pound
pitbull I need to be able to breathe and
have some oxygen to watch you one time I
just sell tickets and just me walking my
dog it's a [ __ ] walking a pitbull yeah
no it's just so cool on and only fans
I'd watch that I watch it and what I
would I want an image of that like just
of like bread jizz - business go I got
probably up some photos on my Instagram
about you can all my fans I feel like if
you really wanted to do if I wanted to
like like do you want to really push
that oh sudden so this is something that
my wife and I did do because we have a
four month old child and my wife sold
her breast milk too so hell yeah
bought to some bodybuilders is that
legal maybe California no you can but
like did she make good money it was like
the same as like a gallon of homogenized
matter how much money no no I don't
think you ask what come on II I think
it's what you just accept that they
I needed the money and they did charge
more if someone says hey man I'm a big
fan of the--of on how much for your used
underwear you like get out of here gross
yeah gross man
and then they like how about 500 grand
you like yeah I get you couple pair and
that's all I'm thinking about like
breast milk it's like here I am being on
judgy
yeah then when I hear the amount I'm
gonna go alright it was it was more than
a gallon of milk Wow and so people what
they a device was and what you weren't
sending more than a gallon of oh no no
that would take a while know the price
the other prize was your wife yeah yeah
hydrated now how do you are when they
get that what do you put it in like a
little bag or sit yeah there's a there's
a bag there because my wife would also
donate breast milk to do some hospitals
to wear it like so like Mad Max yeah
sure pulling that milk out the lady
right there yeah I've never had it
actually I had a little I think a girl
put some on my lawn
but this is at a restaurant dude this is
like clothes this is after the
restaurant a club okay was still in
there okay what did you like did you
like get it from the source that you
like squirt across the room or from the
source Tucson a lady was in May or an
acquittal put a little person in the ng
Miss bobbye's got no mirrors she's
cutting hair you got worse hair at a
restaurant a family dining establishment
gave you breast milk from the sores put
a little on her finger but what are
these men doing with that bread when
they got they were bodybuilders
and so breast milk allegedly has like a
higher protein like some BOTS so like
some bought some bodybuilders really
like to have breast milk so I've got
some friends that are in that community
and and once they found out the less you
but we get no ahead I'm like sure but
pay for yeah I'm gonna give you my baby
I think I'm squeezing my wife out over
here yeah
exactly look at this here it says right
here body mothers are making thousands
of dollars selling their pumped breast
milk online to bodybuilders some body
builders claim breast milk helps build
muscle mass more than any other food I
could see that you know did you about
making money that you feel weird about
uh breast milk is actually much lower in
protein than cow's milk and bodybuilders
pacifically large men need much more
protein oh so they're wrong is a chart
actually that shows like the protein in
breast milk
compared to other milk yeah but it was a
nice little it was a nice little side
hustle oh yeah so I got I got a
goldendoodle right I just got him he's
like Oh beautiful now yeah great dog and
every time there's been times people go
you're gonna get him neutered and I say
yeah I'm not yet he's only six much not
to haven't even dropped and then one
lady she goes oh you're not gonna neuter
him are you and how's it going one of
these people right mhm
and so I was like well I mean I don't
know probably haven't thought about it
she's like well you know it's good money
has it one and she goes oh well like
what you can do is you can there's like
a stud fee we're basically like if you
want your dog to have sex you'll like
Adele someone will take your dog for a
few hours
bring them back your dog is you just get
to have sex and then they come back and
hand you a check for a pretty good
amount Wow yeah okay what happens yeah
that's great watching my dog need sex
anyways I'm not gonna watch but like
they want to take him off my hands full
in a while he can go do that they said
give me a thousand bucks and then my dog
comes back all happy and tired I think
that's a pretty good deal and you got a
fat G yeah it's not like a goldendoodle
girl is gonna show up on our doorstep
like you know my father lives here right
yeah we need some child support like it
seems like a totally avoiding it
scratching at the bottom of the door
here it says right here in one cup of
breast milk yeah
you have 20 you have 2.5 grams 2.5 grams
if that's not much protein that's not
yeah cuz it cow's milk has 12 grams is
that comparing it eight and you see the
other there eight grams in cow's milk
whole eight grams and one percent eight
grams and skim yeah so it's less so it
has the same amount as like almond milk
virtually all right well there you go
just not even milk it's just nut water
yeah
they go bodybuilding yeah all my kids
just nut water I know he's getting milk
they should call it nut water they
really should cuz they they soak the
almonds in water nut juice or nut milk
I mean nut water I mean that they should
have like a rogue god
almond milk company and that's they
would do to like separate themselves
yeah ed milk out there and where do you
drop that off in person do you leave
that at the door how do they go for the
breast milk bodybuilders yeah we dropped
it off in person Wow Wow
I love that dude I like making it yeah
he's in there pumping now buy my urine
I'd be like sure I'll get you as much as
you want you just keeping her hider do
you keep buying her Gatorades every
other 7-eleven yes that's like hair man
hairs free man yeah it was great because
yeah there's never a good time to go
through a pandemic but like we got the
baby at home so it's like and thankfully
my wife you know the baby breastfeed so
it's like that's a renewable food source
it's like I didn't have to go out and
buy baby food or anything like that we
just had food for the baby it was great
yeah that's us support for this past
weekend comes from manscaped who is
number one in men's below-the-belt
grooming i will let you know it is
manscaped they offer precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
baby that low box you know what I'm
talking about
crotch it's time to take care of your
junk manscape does something that other
places don't do they have a mower it is
called the lawn mower 2.0 it's
waterproof and it's skin safe technology
so you can't fricking grip your own sack
you can't get it stuck up into your
pubis or anything like that you can take
care of your body make it look classy
give you dick that fade it always wanted
it's time to take care of your body in
the perfect package 2.0 not only
includes that lawn mower it also
includes anti chafing boxer briefs that
keep you feeling comfortable in the
lowdown for on-the-go freshness you'll
love the crop Reviver ball toner spray
you'll be able to take them balls
anywhere oh it's go time for your bag
support this past weekend podcast I know
you hear a lot of ads but we need to
love get 20% off and free shipping with
the code Theo at manscaped comm that's
right get 20% off and free shipping with
20% off with Free Shipping at manscape
calm and use code th e Oh what um so
what what else was there like from the
shows I'm trying to think like after the
show like did the energy did the energy
feel the same like in the room during
the show yeah but more I thought more
just Liz everyone was just so excited to
be out like and there were lines that I
would say that I would thought like
alright it's kind of a throwaway line
and just something casual and then it
would get a little reaction I'm like oh
yeah it felt like a full room for ya
really yeah like that's awesome
I wrote a real basic joke about how like
like every when the virus happen every
company had had to put out their
coronavirus commercial where they're
just like every commercial right now
it's stuff it starts off we're gonna get
through this yeah like we did we get
that in trying times and all I said was
like this every we don't need every
company's response to coronavirus and
there was a cheer in the room I'm like
oh that's true okay
people feel that way yeah it's like I
it's like I get it AT&T insurance let
let me know what you're doing to lower
my rates or whatever but there's
literally a commercial from Oreo [ __ ]
cookie yeah I was getting emails from
like Wells Fargo like don't worry yeah
I'm not worried about you your bank
you'll be fine
you're Greenglass we're fine yeah can we
our ATMs are clean yes so like it's like
yeah it's like Coca Cola's like here's
what we're doing it's like yeah no
you're making sugar water that's what
you're doing no it's fine no I would say
the thing I was most most nervous about
and again this is selfish I just thought
I might be rusty this is the longest oh
god yeah - fifteen years so I was like I
was afraid I'd be rusty but then being
so generous and then also I realized I
wasn't
that rusty like I was I felt rusty on
that virtual show did it feel weird did
it feel weird going back into like like
cuz like if I were to get back on stage
I'm like I have some new stuff I would
kind of do but otherwise it's like you
got to change all the bits and I was
like just in the verbage so I could you
know I usually get up there I go just
got back from Mexico so I go to all my
Mexico stuff right I can't say okay or
like if I want to make a joke about
something that happen between me and a
girl I'll usually lie and be like I took
this girl on a date like you know the
other day or like last week yeah now I
can say that yes I I had to be like I
remember I think it was last year I took
this girl on a date yeah but even that
little adjustment was hard to do like
anything so dishonest and like so but
yeah I know I haven't been doing
anything right yeah there there there's
a bit I do about how like I'm it's
something that my neighbor said to me
because I'm never home I'm always
traveling yeah so then my neighbor saw
me in front of my house and then said
something to me like I didn't live in my
house right it's like I can't do that no
it's cuz it's like no no I've been home
for three months they know me now I
would start jokes like I would start
talking the guy I got to change this
like yeah you know that quick math you
do in your head right that's like it oh
yeah
yeah only a comic would notice or only
like I you know yeah I would I was
liking it too where if you've ever done
those shows to the Laugh Factory on like
Christmas and Thanksgiving where they
feed the homeless and then they have you
didn't have the comics go onstage and
perform for the homeless there's some
bits you don't want to do right for
homeless people like you know and your
car braked oh yeah here yeah this dinner
is pretty good where's all the huge
delay what I remember watching Joe Cole
in one of these shows and this is years
ago and he was doing his bit about like
orange chicken and Panda Express keys
he's like you guys know what he's like
you guys know that's pretty like they're
like of course we take a [ __ ] in there
but like know all the business I like no
one knew about it in that room you're
like yeah if you felt bad you felt
condescending you felt like I but that's
a does is really just and then Paul
Mooney just went on stage and
stroyed the room oh really wasn't he
homeless now in other words I'm not oh
he had a special out a couple years ago
he did yeah I mean he could also be
homeless now he's just a psycho yeah so
I thought he's like you know a lot of
homeless people or psychos oh yeah what
they're easily able to talk to him
dude the homeless people in my sauce jog
in the other day and there's a homeless
like I live right by a park over in
Westwood and so there's a lot of
homeless now but living in the park but
they got campers the city got campers
and put them up since the virus got the
campers and putting me in different
campers so a lot of times at night yes
really it's really pretty nice they're
nice they're nice campers I'll jog by at
night and the other night I'm jogging by
and there's a guy out there smoking out
on the he's like sitting like on the
step of the open door of his camper and
he's got music going and and it's like
James Brown or something something
pretty fun pretty loud and then behind
him there's a truck a sewage truck
backing up there's a guy with a hose in
a full hazmat suit and PPP like the
shield and everything walking up to it
with a to drain the sewage out of a
camper and I'm just like this is so
bizarre I'm like here you have a
homeless guy yeah who's you know just
doing whatever he wants yeah and then
you have like how much is this costing
about this huge guy yes I mean in
literally walking up like he was what
like he was an Armageddon or something
yeah like so scared full bodysuit want
and a hand a mic and this dude's job is
to deal with the piss and [ __ ] of
homeless people that's true I better I'd
be sleeping in a head I need a cup of
breath yeah telling jokes to some
middle-class people in Utah yeah I mean
this dude is yeah that's the job did it
feel like it was just saw the audience's
that came out that I feel like it was
just rich people or anything I had that
vibe I just felt like just regular P
it's all walks alive because there was
there was definitely people that do you
ever have someone come to your show and
tell and tell you all the struggles that
they're going through and you're like
bro maybe you shouldn't be spending
money on the comedy show right now like
because there
there was some people that I got some
messages afterward it's like yeah the
whole family like lost our jobs and no
no and we haven't had anything yeah and
we're all drinking each other's breasts
yeah and our lights went out but man the
fact that your show we bought tickets to
your show and like 450 450 dollars a
ticket was worth every penny
yeah fifteen dollars ticket scalper but
like but like there there there are some
people where you're like whoa don't
don't like save your money like save
your money for but then there was some
other guy that because I wasn't doing
the meet-and-greet I wasn't selling
merch and I got this message from a guy
that was like hey you didn't sell merch
this week oh no he goes so you probably
lost out and some money I go yeah he
goes what's your venmo and he then mode
me a little bit of money and I'm like
okay Wow and so thank you that guy yeah
Wow were you were you guys allowed were
you allowed to sell merch there I could
my feature XL merch
so I could if I wanted to which now they
think about it the fact that my feature
X Sol merch and that and then we were in
the green room together probably
defeated that whole purpose of me not
selling merch but skipping me angry
didn't help any yeah yeah yeah yeah
nobody wanted it yeah I think that old
my old album that like most of the been
out for years yeah and also its CD oh
yeah I just sell CDs ooh brother
craziest part was I used to bring the
chart the CD duplicator on the road I
had one of those yeah you're working
anyway saying read on it it would say
read on it whenever it like started to
get the disc and then you would lust
you'd hear it heating up I had like one
of us pretty cheap so it would heat
really hot like I'm the cran would start
going
who knows if some of those even work oh
that's a roll the dice God what are your
zis is blank like that happens man yeah
I'm doing three at a time
yeah sorry lucky lucky lucky city is
humiliated when people tell me they got
that like just take this new one for
free yeah that's fine I have your first
album no you do not forgot about that
and I would go by this to the clear
cases and put it in and then see rocks
and cut the frickin thing and put it
here and sell them yeah now it's like
you just have a now they already have
your album or they can stream it for
free like it's hot like that's what
sucks is because merch is a big way for
comics to make money oh yeah and they
get a few hundred bucks it's huge it's
tough to like not have something to sell
to them yeah yeah so yeah you had to
leave a lot of money on the table if you
didn't sell merch but you know it's just
I'll get to that point and if you want
to buy some bread ones merch and Jessica
just go to Brad Williams comedy calm the
commercial I'll send it to you the good
thing is you probably know like okay I'm
just gonna bring 30 or 40 shirt you know
it's like I'm only gonna bring this many
things because it's because so it and
where you were at Salt Lake City it was
a hundred people yeah I think is a
hundred people per show yeah me it was
like huh between hundred and twenty-five
Wow per show yeah I tell you what saved
my life during the damn pandemic was a
beam on cameo that's a really that saved
my ass cuz st. Patrick's Day happened
and I said and I said on my social media
that oh nice I was that i will send i
will dress up as a leprechaun and send a
message personalized message god I made
so much money
the best ones thank God sort of like
stick you know like Scott Steiner that
old wrestler he's like oh his arm where
Jamie and I'll Punk your wife I'll do
whatever you want I like yeah I'll run a
what does that call its train no that's
a Knick was thinking more than a spider
but yeah cut a pro just think oh he and
his brother always did everything to go
second Haman was a hilarious cuz that
and so he just talk [ __ ] to these people
yeah good yeah and why is he dressed
like that's how I was WCW kind of like
gimmick when he would come out we're in
that closet
yeah I missed the open be the old man he
had the odd the things on is the
wrestling that's Rick his brother yeah
yeah University of maybe we should just
like a strong weird collegiate wrestler
like big there and then Rick would come
out like a dog and like a pee on the
turn but yeah Rick was crazy there they
go but then then that seemed to go to
the next one the steroids got that's
like the Maggie that yeah and he and
he's like 50 look at this biceps you
can't build a bicep like that guy will
buy your breast milk right there man
right now
that is got if you're listening stop
you've got so he's like Arnold what is
it like were you duh we're drug dealers
like steal drugs but then they used him
sometimes he no I love how every sports
league shut down and Pro Wrestling was
like [ __ ] y'all dude killed a wrestler
on accident and then sued his wife for
breach of contract
that's how evil does not care at all the
only reason he didn't do WrestleMania in
Tampa as scheduled is get the city of
Tampa had to be like hey man you can't
right he's like they had to interfere
you can't do it yeah how much money this
makes me damn it dude a lot of places
are um there's like a lot of push back
now it seems like because cities are
saying you can do certain things then we
have an article maybe something about
that Nick there's cities saying you can
do certain things but then people are
now like filing lawsuits that they just
can't take it anymore
well something doesn't make sense to me
is like they've said all right the
lockdown is gonna be three more months
but also we're opening businesses you
look right yet truly confused it's very
confusing to me yeah you see some
articles go to the article man doesn't
it okay
and it reducing the spread of Isis we're
now facing legal challenges from
residents and state officials alike one
of these is pretty wild
you can't be student government right
now they're already giving all their
money to people and I'm stuck at home
that's tough but it but I get the
frustration like your risk you you want
to make money you really go out make
money and then the government says no
stay home and don't make money and
you're like oh so you're gonna pay me
well no we're gonna give you like what
Ricki the government isn't making the
virus like the government so we're
trying to kind of save your ass like
it's tricky it's like the wrong person
absolutely like look at Tech in Texas as
the Attorney General warned that he
could take action against the cities of
Austin San Antonio and Dallas if they do
not scale back orders that are more
restrictive and that's the Attorney
General then the governor is moving
towards reopening the state and said
that while business have the freedom to
reopen or remain closed local
governments do not have the option to
keep them closed
California faces dozen lawsuits that
claim the state has unjustly closed down
gun shops and religious services and
fringe down freedoms of speech and
assembly what do you think about that
about a religious services yeah I think
it's kind of like stand up man you got
to go to that responsibly Yeah right
that's what I said like if you want to
go to it big go to it but just like you
got like you got to understand that's
one of my biggest things and this is it
might make you some of the listeners
annoyed people don't take like their own
responsibility so like right they'll
smoke for 40 years and then go isn't it
sad I have cancer it's like no dude yeah
yes we love your mom but like you don't
get to smoke for 40
oh well I need disability because I'm a
big fat lardo and I ate McDonald's 75
times in one day for the last 30 hours
no response and so it's like do they all
want healthcare but like a lot of the
health care like you don't even take
precautions like that's the beauty of
freedom is that we get to do what we
want you don't get to do what you want
and then be a victim yeah I'll get to go
like well I should be able to jog
through the park naked and no but yes
but that's not the reality we live in
right yeah can't you drive the bartnik
it stuffs gonna happen yeah you don't
like things if you're a lion tamer for
the circus and the lion bites your arm
up yes you can't sue this third part of
it yeah and also I love that your lion
tamer but don't cry to me when your
honor
yeah and if you want to eat McDonald's
75 times I love that but don't cry too
about your diabetes that's how that
works yeah I wonder if there's a way
though cause like it's me actually let's
do this sorry that's another one
if I get coronavirus tomorrow that's my
fault
cuz I had cuz we waited yet who's doing
comedy shows because we went it's the
same thing of like person responsibility
like that's on me yeah it's like it'd be
way safer if no one played professional
football right but these guys yeah yeah
argument oh I was like man these fall
players keep getting hurt but it's like
but they're playing football right they
signed up to play football there was a
doctor a weaker a week ago I think who
put a pitcher he's on up airplane he's
flying from New York to San Francisco
and it's a full plane and he's like I
can't believe they said that this that
this plane is full you know this is so
dangerous it's like him in 25 doctors
but it's like but you're on the plane
right like if you don't want to be like
it's just it's like we want our creature
comforts but once they start to like I
don't know yeah I know I'm saying hi
that's the toll road I was going down
it's like week everyone is so victim II
and soft about that kind of stuff it's
so frustrating yeah here you go dr.
Ethan Weiss I guess unites relaxing
social system policy these days every
seat full on this 737 yeah and I but at
that point you have the opportunity if
you want to get off the plane yeah it's
you you have the freedom to make those
kind of decisions I know that when I
flew on on American Airlines there was a
couple in front of me that had their
that had their infant child like and
there and I just kept thinking myself
why does that why does that baby have to
fly right right like but okay oh yes
that's your [ __ ] why not even go step
further this might like so I would say
like oh maybe they should have drove you
know like don't be on a crowded plane
where we share air with other people
yeah maybe they should have drove rent a
car drive to wherever this emergency
destination is that you're taking his
infant right and then people will say Oh
Jeff what if they can't afford it well
they should have get a better job they
should have worked hard like I'd like
even those things to say well some
people can't well then work hard just
take your burden and bear it if you're
broke get rich if you're fat you don't
like it lose weight if you've got your
happy great flaunt it what you just
do whatever is working for you hey I
mean like do better yeah there has to be
some social ricourt the other there's no
responsive like there's we keep making
it so like we always just keep helping
the lowest common denominator which in
America you can be like I mean I
remember up in India before and like
they'll have handicapped people like
dragging themselves on the ground
because they don't have a wheelchair
they don't or like if they're lucky to
get like a skateboard or something or
make something like that you know where
it's like in the US it's like everything
we really get catered to I'm not really
comfortable but they keep like catering
to like okay somebody can you know not
do anything their whole life live in a
bubble you know the worst yeah file come
out once a gun down both their parents
you know who aren't without thumbs so
you know we better send him a check
every month and he's like well I can't
work I got no thumbs like dude and I
learned all this like my ideologies from
traveling the world and I see things
that I got man if they can do it I was
poor lived in a car and I started doing
I found a job where I didn't need a high
school diploma or I didn't like I found
a giant works no I'm a [ __ ] so I need
to find a job where morons can figure it
out do what you gotta do and righties
morons with like make millions at least
they found a scam to get money like that
the great I find something you know do
what you gotta do it's like I can't be a
professional basketball player cuz you
know you define another way cuz I'm
white right yeah but like so I found a
job where I could I could be
professional figure it out do it did you
ever did you ever think cuz you were a
smaller person bred and that um in
stature only that you are think that you
should have got like a extra something
from the government or any show so every
dwarf gets a TLC show it's gonna be like
they just have the dwarf Network we got
out we got it we got the WWE Network you
got like DIY Network's just have the
dwarf Network because now all dwarf
shows all the time serious yeah the only
problem shows is they're always trying
to convince that there's nothing
unordinary right the entire time we're
just like everyone else
no no we're not you're not like everyone
I'm not like these
super boring yeah they got runs and
jumps up into bed we want to see how you
how you're navigating your life because
it's inspirational to know that you're
reg that you're just like all of us yeah
except you're dealing with something
that makes you different than us but
like hell yeah I'm not like everybody
else because I have to put my bag up at
the up in the overhead storage bin and I
got to get [ __ ] creative guys don't
come up to me like that never is
different okay yeah we just
but yeah it's like we don't make people
we don't make people like have to be
better than cells really you know it's
like we'll just keep making it more
comfortable we don't challenge it
doesn't seem like we challenge look at
food people just eat for taste yeah all
they care about is their mouths and let
food is to feel you it's supposed to
like make your body operate at a high
level of it but we just all we care
about is the taste part it be like
filling your car up with like Mountain
Dew just everyday and then the engine
seizes in the mechanic a doctor is like
dude have you been putting soda pop in
this car he loves me no this runs on
fuel and you're like dude loves you
enough to keep coming here yeah and
she's gonna have to be stripped and
figure every single time you put
Mountain doing this thing what do you
know we do with our own bodies we get
one body in our entire life and we just
put [ __ ] in it and then once we get like
240 we realize we've got you know
problems and we need pills and we get
them that's the thing in the u.s. we get
him I feel like I wonder if we didn't
have those things like to help us you
know like if we didn't know that like
there's a there's a some bailout program
that's gonna be there there's a way like
if we all went completely broke we know
there's probably a way where we're gonna
get housing somehow and we're gonna get
probably able to be able to get medicine
or parents like yeah yeah it doesn't
make us challenge ourselves any but I
don't know how you do that I don't know
how you will know that like worst-case
scenario you can go stay with your
parents until you get back on your feet
right I like worst-case scenario flike
you're a clean person like if you don't
drink and drugs nothing you'll probably
have a thousand couches you can write
like you'll never be home right if you
can keep up like what you're doing but
people that don't have that that's why
rich kids
statistically famously don't do much
because they did like the comfy they've
never had to write they always know that
backups there there that's what people
might be doing subconsciously with their
health it's gonna take oh yeah I'm sure
I think I I'm sure I've done in my own
life you know I smoked not a ton but I
smoked semi decently probably till about
maybe two months ago now cigarettes yeah
really over two months off cigarettes
yeah but it's like I can't blame it I
definitely feel better God it was the
way you have to yeah that's that's the
correct like whenever I actually eat
like a kale salad with very little salad
dressing on it I go damn it I feel like
a lot better well even the [ __ ] bow of
that if like I'm doing the right thing I
made a good deal good like I have I can
still go walk yeah walk around you know
I never smoked cigarettes because I'm
pretty susceptible to peer pressure I
just want to be part of the gang you
know I want to be mint so like when
everyone is smoking weed they're always
like man this is the best let's get like
a marijuana sweatshirt I'll wear to
school and like weeds the best oh yeah
yeah and like dr. Dre we're to go to
Janine's house we're gonna drink you
guys we want to drink alcohol but even
like so everything looks really good you
can get it anybody who would smoke
cigarettes around me and be like man
don't do this I hate this like wow
there's two wow it's so like I just saw
that commercial was like I'm never gonna
do that I've never seen anyone enjoy a
cigarette that's really care just
sitting there going I can't believe I do
this expensive it stinks I hate it don't
don't ever do this this is bad it's so
true peeler like don't ever do this wow
they're doing it yeah that was me oh I'd
be miserable and [ __ ] smoking yeah
cuz no one ever does that with like good
sex like don't do that yeah yet no one's
ever [ __ ] like a hot person be like
this is horrible
I hate what do you sandwich you like one
of these later it's like what brownies
you're doing it yeah and that comes the
placebo of self-loathing and stuff so
like when you're doing that you're kind
of feeling close like man I shouldn't be
doing this I said I was gonna quit so
there's the opposite effect of that kill
salad psychologically but then so but
then there's so like you know we could
like they have cigarettes people can
have them if they want to right they're
available but do you blame like the
government for allowing though like
there to be cigarettes that people can
have even though they're addictive or
he's free will man you can do whatever
you want
but just don't cry to me when you get
lung cancer yeah yeah
you chose that but good for you I love
that you want to do that yeah it's like
it's like it's like why do we watch the
dude walk across the volcano on the
tightrope cuz in the back your head
you're like wow
I'd never could fall I'd never do that
never a yes and then if that dude fell
in the volcano and died we feel bad for
him no we don't be like well right he
walked across the football I always
think about that with a football analogy
of like they wouldn't have posters of
these guys on my walls as a kid and
think they're like these hero Titans if
it was safe yeah that's what makes me
cooler than my dad is like they can get
those crushed skulls in my head like
literally like throwing footballs 50
it's not like I have a poster of my
stepdad wheelie on my wall here's how he
got his graduate degree from fbw or
whatever he returns he filed a lot last
year's oh yeah what a legend already
caught they had like heroic posters for
this regular dude yeah yeah after
sensenbach he's taught physical
education in school for 40 years what do
we got in the news Nick anything
exciting going on this is kind of funny
chucky cheese because people didn't seem
to be wanting to order them on some of
the food delivery apps they changed
their branding nobody wanted crappy
pizza they changed their branding to
Pasquale's pizza and try and do we
handle urban market ahora that Latino
what does Pasquale's mean Pasquale is
actually a number another member of
chuck-e-cheeses rap band oh no one knows
I hate that I knew that rana crap I love
that you you ever Ollie there's a purple
one and then the Ramos nonnamous though
and then there's the no his name is
munch munch when little people are if
I'm right people when you guys see like
better be munch characters do you guys
feel like there's like a like a sense of
like you it doesn't seem like you like
do you know what I'm talking about
Connor
what like cuz you guys get like a lot of
the same attention I feel like as like
maybe Snow White at Disneyland or like
oh yeah
oh dude like cuz alright when you see
characters like like Pasquale ER like
Chucky's yeah do you feel like I said a
Simba a symbiosis with them like you
feel like kinda so well they all get
stared at but no it was funny because
like my job before I was a comic as I
worked at Disneyland cuz I grew up in
Southern California then that's a great
way for eyes great job yeah it's great
oh yeah great place to be I mean you're
not wrong really a homoerotic hotbed
down I don't know oh yeah Disneyland all
the time with my guy friends
yeah no idea they'd probably graduates
yeah no it was fun cuz I got a lot I got
a lot of attention from the girls that
work there because I was like one of the
only straight dudes what'd you do work
there alright I I was not one of the
seven that's now okay I was a bodyguard
for the characters it's called being a
character host yeah you walk around with
them yeah and just like make sure no the
Seven Dwarfs are actually gigantic when
they in the costume yeah come out
they're huge they're not they should
actually hired Orff's and then make the
costume smaller yeah I should do yes mr.
münch I got it right yes ah the car I'm
a loser current incarnation of the
character is called munches make-believe
and it's his band Chucky
bandleader Helen Hanny mr. münch jasper
gels and Pasquale 'i think if you're
gonna open a restaurant right a
restaurant arcade for children why pick
a rodent to be like them at like that's
the number-one thing you don't want in a
kitchen oh yeah I think like Chucky
Cheese yeah it's a mouse okay TMZ has a
thing out for Chuckie Cheese would you
admit that Nick is out for y'all but TMZ
hate Chucky Cheese everybody waits Chuck
and cheese who is it
my body does Oh your buddy man Jionni
Gianna
Chucky Cheese - I he tweeted something
about it was actually kind of funny he
posted something how he hated people who
were getting takeout from Chuckie Cheese
before this actually happened one of his
friends the next day dropped some off at
his house and a couple hours later
Jionni tweeted Chuckie Cheese is better
than in and out fighting yeah well he
drove cheese he like filmed it with this
phone you know how like oh I skipped
through most leader [ __ ]
but you know how all young people like
that so that's what the new leg youtuber
and chick talk is like them ranting in
their car yeah like that with like quick
edits for some reason we're like just
jumps from like random like that's the
whole video and it's like them just like
taking a hard take on like pineapple he
did like a hard take on how he like it
chuck-e-cheese they should all be closed
they're all creepy the food is shitty
and he did like the whole thing but he
did definitely did it before all this
yeah they go after chucky cheese all the
time there's always I remember they
found a piece of scalp and one of the
ball pits or something and that's what
said it all we used to go on dates I
remember people would do like a mate
like that I remember like if your mom
and somebody else's mom that had like a
cute child or something they would set
you up on a little date at Chucky and
I'll get the other table you'd sit at
one table two parents and the kids would
sit at another chair like a little
double date kind of I always liked their
pizza I might get Pasquale's takeout
really I always thought it was good I
mean it's hard to screw up pizza in my
opinion maybe because I was eight I have
my 34th birthday at chuck-e-cheeses in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and I can only
invite five people why I that's the rule
that was like the amount we paid for in
the package and were they a little
alarmed that it was thirty four-year-old
well the funny part was it would be like
if they had two birthday tables it was
like Hannah six Jonathan for Thea Hook
34 yeah and then the gig ban would come
by I loved it man you know uh so this is
a bit I do on stage so I'm gonna try to
not do it as it's a bit true story I
went to Legoland on my day off in Kansas
City mm-hmm and just me as I got I could
spend a day at Legoland I'll just check
it out it like I do Disneyland or
something I was gonna convince one of my
guy friends to come down and so I get
that parking line I felt too weird being
alone
Legoland psychology yeah darica sake
I'll just wait in the car till you get
here he gets there I'm 30 I think I was
35 at the time my buddy Derek's like 37
or something so we meet we go to the
front gate and they wouldn't sell us
tickets to come to Chuckie to go to
Legoland really and I said what's why
and they go cuz you have to have like a
kid with you we don't have kids
and like yeah but we don't just let
random men walk around respect and I was
according me they're like we have adult
night twice a month
and if you want to come to adult nights
like I'm not here for adult night I'd
I'm only in town this week I want to go
to Legoland Wow and they were like well
and Isaac why are you doing this and
like well because we don't want you know
kidnappings we'd you know we're trying
to prevent I was like well you're gonna
cause a kidnapping somebody go steal a
kid to get into Legoland well also like
would I be the best kidnapper in the
world like that he would be so happy if
I got it great that never takes me the
leg interesting now drop me back up at
home no sex just fine yeah now with a
less green now would they let two women
go go into Legoland with without k we
should test it I don't know because they
were already late weird it's a good
point cuz like alright because I've kind
of a similar story I was at a mall and I
they got those I think they're called
busy bees it's like it's like a Chuckie
Cheese there's tubes and ball pits and
[ __ ]
and I was in the middle of the Midwest
doing shows and I'm by myself I'm like
you know what [ __ ] it I guess don't fit
in those tubes let's go let's go to busy
bees so I so I start walking in there
and they got like a an employee stops me
and it goes like hey do you have a you
have a kid in there and I go now I just
want to go in there and like I'm small
enough to run around the tubes ago yeah
we can't we can't let you do that I'm
like you know what in this case probably
a good idea just some single white hand
just walks and just like yeah I want to
go run around the kids does it feel like
a lodge way to the bathroom shaved
everything I'm a kid and I'm late for
school you seen people yeah you mr.
Thomas has grandpa's favorite on it does
it feel a lot of times like you because
of your size and something you get to
relive your childhood in some instances
that look yes wow that's pretty cool
think about that that [ __ ] oh there's a
their mouth like a good one
my favorite ride is a Knott's Berry Farm
Camp Snoopy
it's called huff and puff hmm and I
could still ride that ride my friends
can't oh we can't we're too big too big
look up huff and puff you'll see why
it's a train that you sit on oh cool and
then you like you can like move the
thing back and forth and then that
controls your speeding train oh yeah
they're gonna pay you to like be the guy
there it is there it is look at that
I can still do that durable oh yeah it's
awesome it's Bobby Lee and his girl that
it's like it's all it's always funny
when I would do it because out cuz I cuz
I would go to Knott's Berry Farm and
just be you know I'd be with my friends
be like hold on I go ride huff and puff
real quick that's great and like I take
photos there must be a photo yes so
there's like a video somewhere of like
the train going by and it's like yeah I
bet the people love that to the amidgett
Ryan huff and puff won't get off for 25
it's awesome I go yeah well if I can't
write some of the rollercoasters then
the payoff of that is I can still ride
the kid that's great you can ride yeah
and then I was watching them I was
watching the Chicago Bulls documentary
and I said when I was hearing about how
like a Air Jordans are costing people
like $175 and I'm like oh wow they've
only cost like 50 bucks for me really oh
that's a guy think about three years
it cost me 50 bucks I always think about
I wonder what I wonder what the cost of
savings is if you're a little person
overall life well for there you get
savings but then you buy like a pair of
pants and then you got to get them
altered and [ __ ] like that or or god
forbid you buy a suit I got a couple of
suits that cost me a little extra money
oh really yeah because I had a tailor
suit anyway so it's weird that they that
must've gotten easier as you got older
yeah with like the Internet in modern
times right yeah cuz now there's like
services I'm sure some of them even
sponsor your podcast where like you like
measure your [ __ ] and you send it off to
them as a kid must be nightmare yeah
that's horrible now it's like yeah now
there's like great places that do that
do that
did you always not to ask questions I
don't know any other little people
except for you or different types of
people that aren't I'll be your dwarf
Google's super tall yeah but do you did
you always know that you were at a
certain point did your parents sit you
down and say hey man we have something
to tell you
oh so they told me I was a dwarf but
they told me before I went off to school
because
dad my family is all tall so my dad told
me he's like no when you go to school
there's gonna be some kids and make fun
of you because you're a dwarf so lets
you and I write some comebacks for them
nice oh my god yeah so my dad and I
wrote jokes
my dad was like just stop being a [ __ ]
why are you crying yeah kids pick on
kids grow up yeah yeah so like so like
we wrote jokes so then when I went to
school and kids made fun of me I had
comebacks like written nice and I and I
would say it to them and then they get
all sad and I get I got sent to the
principal's office you feel bad stealing
your dad's material did you do you think
that they'd help make you into a
comedian that's all yeah exactly oh you
know I would become a comedian yeah what
also just being different it's probably
why you're yeah that too that well but
like but that attitude with being
different right that's why that's
probably why I'm well makes you funny
yeah so then when like when I go to some
city and some guy like yells out
leprechaun I'm like really you think I
haven't heard that [ __ ] before let's go
okay like like it and then I fire back
at him well he's never been funny that
guy if he's still yelling at epic on if
this airs like that guy how sad is it
how sad is it as we get older when you
have your friends that still tell like
jokes that are just like from Gras or
just like the worse like little
comebacks or whatever Vegas pepper you
know the worst one is is when people
especially grown men mm-hmm and grown
women anyone I'd say over the age of 11
if you think you're funny cuz you're
saying like a line from a happy gilmore
movie yeah more like you're quoting
Michael Scott from life you stole a
quote from a thing and now you're put in
your own life and you think you're very
funny like you suck you're not funny
okay you're my boy blue somebody yeah
except this one guy who did a quick
video he had a friend that had drowned
or something he's like you're my boy
blue and he kept [ __ ] turning the
camera to the [ __ ] body how crazy is
that
see that's what that guy said so
humorous I know that was your blue my
boy
different that's good and a fish that
that's like I don't fear anything about
like being a dad in terms of stuff that
I'm gonna do with my daughter the thing
the thing that I fear is like once I
have to start interacting with other
parents who just aren't funny and you
know you have to put up with it then
they find another comic no you can be
polite but like you don't have to like
you don't know I mean ya know when they
find out you're a comic that has to be
the worst when you have a child think
about that you have a child you have a
disconnection piece somebody else said
as a child so you have to mill around
where your children do whatever they're
doing liquids are brands yeah oh my god
now I have to like you're friends with
Sally so we doesn't deal with it he can
just go jump in the ball pit try running
around the tubes dude I can't wait for
that day when me and my daughter are
both running around the tubes of Chucky
Cheese oh I'm I'm gonna go back to that
busy busy listen you're making here dad
tell bad jokes I'm gonna jump around
playing the to the kids do that's
hilarious is your daughter
Dorf yes right yeah yeah got the asian
dwarf baby or or as I like to call da DB
wait were you hoping for a dwarf yeah
okay yeah well cuz like I want I don't
want my kid to grow older and get bigger
than me and I got like discipline er go
to your room well now she's kind of on
your team it comes down to like you and
you know you and your wife or have you
know now it's kind of like team door fit
in the house oh yeah now it's like my
wife can't complain if she like trips
over a stepstool or something because I
like this is the world you're living in
now this is you you signed up for this
she was like she was an average height
person now you're out yeah look at that
smile is so cute ah yeah is there
another one that's the picture behind it
that's my baby yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
my wife is Chinese so we made an agent
Wharf baby and what are the odds that
she was gonna be a door 50/50 Wow
yeah so we were you know we were just
kind of uh that's that that might be my
favorite one she cute someone gave her a
robe with her
with her initials on it some pesto I
knew it was probably somebody who tries
to get into a Lego Lane by themself
that's it
don't put that on me also that person
has no idea how newborn babies or Dwarfs
work that's a giant robe that's like for
like a wonder like two year old that's
the best part is like because like we
know all when all the pandemic stuff
started happening or some people started
talking me like oh wow that's gonna
that's gonna suck when like your kid out
grows her clothes like no we got clothes
for like what you guys yeah we're
hunkered down we're good I'm at the
worst of it when I buy clothes for like
my nieces and nephews or something like
I was like like I don't know he's like
fours just fit like I'm like holding up
like I'm like at Target like oh and it
looks pretty little to me but like if
you're calling over another
four-year-olds ride is Chuckie Cheese
after town oh four year old like hey try
this on try this on come out do ill turn
for me let's see how it fits
do they sell lingerie for a little be no
dude and no not for lottery I think even
for children is there that's my point it
would be the same no it's not it's not
because we got big asses and my type of
dwarfism the girls have some big old
titties wow she's gonna have to oh wow
it's be like you'd have to have
customized lingerie yeah sometimes it's
customized always right but I think for
the most part stuff just fits because
like not as much stuff fits but there's
stuff that fits oh there is yeah yeah
it's out there I don't say that we'll
get a real dark world Oh Bronx fan huh
yeah there you go
she is look she's not a bra I could put
me in this second one I got all of the
line la baby is she getting to the part
where she can you said four months yeah
wow yeah I love like five six months
they start to really kind of get
interactive and stuff yeah like dude
like and not not to get like too cheesy
or whatever but like when it it crushes
me in the best way when I when she's
when I wake her up in the morning and I
walk in she's kind of crying then she
looks up and sees me and then just gets
a big smile on her face best like that I
like it sounds stupid and cheesy and
that's human literally the best feeling
I've ever had in the world I love that
is is just my daughter like look at me
and smiling it's the best feeling I've
ever had
better than Saturday Late Show when
they're like you hit all your bonuses
[Laughter]
that's a damn good yeah yeah you know
it's certain certain things like that
and I got friends that don't have kids
and they're like how do you like you
change diapers and stuff you're like
yeah yeah you do
like Wow will you like wipe and [ __ ]
yeah yeah is that Adam Rea said that
sounded just like him a thousand no it
might like what yeah it's like he sound
like you can like a marriage diver
oh yeah you like your daughter she's
like yeah kind of it because if you
don't they're just in their own [ __ ] and
you don't think about it also I'm not a
monster
yeah let my wife do it numb of like yeah
I mean like look life is 1950s Mad Men
dad where I'm just in the other room
with the martini like how that [ __ ]
honey yeah okay that might be the bad
part of having a dwarf daughter like you
rooted for because now she can about you
if you guys get in a fight oh you're the
Dorf
you change her now it's teen Dorf I'm
some big on this there's like an average
person war going on in their house well
if something has if something shits near
me I'm gonna help it out that's where
I'm at I don't care why I got old
parents right yeah that's true I like I
feel like I feel like you should play
the more you know theme write it right
after you say that if something shits
near me I'm gonna help it out which is
crazy let's sometimes she'd only be
running like who's that where's that my
idea yeah what else we got Nick any
other news Brad did have a heart out at
oh yeah yeah
I gotta go cuz my wife hasn't boy yeah
and uh and then I need to go watch the
baby because honey guys cuz you can't
just put the baby in the crib he'll say
deuces it's not like my puppy that's
sitting in the kennel right now oh yeah
you you you guys continue but uh you
might do mind pop plugs I'm sure no
let's plug it man where can people check
you out uh Brad Williams comedy comm on
Instagram at Browns comic Twitter at
funny Brad please check out my tour
schedule because it changes almost by
the week as like cuz like things get
cancelled but then other states open up
so they get added like so things are
changing constantly so yeah just go just
go to the website and book me on cameo
yeah good cameo dot-com slash Brad
Williams comic the best one I've had so
far is one woman told me to tell her
ex-girlfriend that her [ __ ] was stanky
oh my god thankee not think she paid for
some I guess thanks good yeah it was on
a medical term on that it's a stanky
[ __ ] guys medical I think you nailed it
yeah so you know there's some real
outliers out there yeah so you know what
go and book me on cameo I'll do it like
yeah I'm not gonna say it I'm not gonna
say a racial slur or anything like that
but if you want me to call someone's
[ __ ] stanky man yeah yeah look for 500
oz you want to dress up like a Duane
Chapman the Bounty Hunter rest up is a
small Scott Steiner oh you'll just do
the smaller gimmick probably would be
funny for say like for $300
yeah $300 you're like I will do a small
version of whatever your favorite so
I'll do a small dog to bunny hunter I'll
do a smaller vaginitis it's called or
trichomoniasis Wow that's what the women
can have and it is ladies out you put
whatever word you want on a get it fixed
yeah tomato potato yeah baby yeah thank
you so much man congratulations on the
you guys make one month old thank you
for having me yeah man you bet love you
brother
this will go up tonight okay yeah this
is a tough wall to have to change um you
know likes not like at the Comedy Store
but they just put your name and cursive
on the wall yeah for this you got it you
want to add someone you want to take
someone away that's quite a thing yeah
well we had a but we have a guy makes it
who does animation that helps us out and
we don't have a guy like I'm but we have
a guy who does some awesome animation
that we know that's got Papio tuned and
so he drew this one time kind of based
on the Simpsons characters kind of and
very much so I have no idea I'm not a
big fence in Seattle but okay cool
so then yeah then then we just blew it
up and put it on here it's so good yeah
it's pretty cool man then it's
definitely been something that people
like to see um yeah man just so crazy
you guys went out there and got into it
I loved it I was excited I wanted to get
out there man like they could have said
that like I said the money is the tricky
part yeah but I think if you did it or
if like I think Joe Rogan is gonna go to
the gonna go to wiseguys that's what the
the rumor is around there
Keith Stubbs the owner was like yeah
Joe's gonna go and I'm already gonna do
just make it like $100 a ticket but
there's still limited to like the
hundred people right and he's like yeah
something like that will probably make
the tickets 40 bucks or something like
that and put a hundred people in I was
like wow oh yeah yeah I guess there's
certainly ways to do it like um it's
also it should be noted like it wasn't
like I sought it out like I didn't go
like hey if someone booked me the offer
came through and I was like really
what does Utah not have news like how
does this work yeah and then I just like
sure I guess I'll just say yes the way I
always do well I was in Utah few weeks
ago we went camping in southern Utah
nice or cou a lot of people call it so
you but they had on we went to
restaurants and stuff so we went in a
tin restaurant I went to a gay bar after
the show it was like the closest bar
that was open the old distance you know
so I got to go to the gay one we went
into the bar and was just like a
restaurant like feel like oh you have to
sit at a table you can't go anywhere you
have to stay with your people and if you
need to go the bathroom something get up
but you got to put your mask on I said
well this isn't a bar yeah what I like
about bars you can walk around talk to
people and stuff I guess
kick someone you don't know it's fun
yeah I miss the old bars you don't drink
anymore right uh-uh right but you still
will go to a bar oh yeah good socialize
yeah it's fun I mean I think it's fun
sometimes but I don't like I noticed
that I start to not like is when people
especially women but if somebody's
really wasted oh yeah just like that
gets a request if you're not drinking
that [ __ ] is a such a curveball what's
this guy's name
trying to think of this name of this guy
is a comedian and I should know his name
I'm just blanking on it he's like uh gay
Jimmy is that that guy doesn't matter
was anyways he don't drink and he's like
oh I think you're going the other way
drinks a lot hey Jimmy he's a real
sipper now there's a guy who doesn't
drink any open for me and he was outside
do you still wanna come out of his
effort because yeah I just I just won't
drink so we go and he left because he
was so annoyed with how hammered the
girl was that I was talking about he was
like I could even be around her like I
was just so embarrassed for her and so
annoyed and I was like if Jeff can put
up with us he can put up with it but I'm
on it
and I was like man I've never even
thought about that it's kind of like one
of the perks of being the being drunk
too it's one of the perks of being don't
even notice that everyone else is yet
makes you judge male that's one thing I
don't like a little bit of definitely
adds a level of like kind of like what I
think comes off to other people as
judgement so now I'm like if people are
drunk somewhere you know and you're not
you're like oh man this girl's weight
like I just can't communicate with this
person you know yeah if you had two
drinks you'd probably be fine talking to
him you know that's when I already
stopped drinking I was like I considered
it I actually considered for the first
time in my life not drinking really yeah
because Jordan Peters always talks about
that all the time yeah he's like a big
on all that stuff and but then I just
like I don't think I can which might
mean I have a problem no I'm gonna I
don't know it'll I mean we don't cross
paths a ton so I don't know if I've ever
seen you so I don't know this guy guys
are it's like you're like oh this dude
problem yeah this yes I'm always having
fun you know the guy and I don't have a
wife or girlfriend or kids or anything
so like it doesn't affect me that it's
never negatively affected that you're
probably fine yeah yeah yeah I'm I go to
yoga every day after like the next day
sweat it all out and you know
I don't know that you having a [ __ ]
blast this great life but also like that
does make me win when guys I had my I'm
like oh man they stopped maybe I don't
know maybe I should stop yeah thinks
sometimes it's like yeah you start to
think is there like insider trade like
am i it would it help me like maybe
start working more am I gonna like start
like organizing things like a I'll knock
out seven podcasts in a day because I
had so much I didn't sleep in until
10:30 I don't know yeah do you feel more
productive I think I have over the past
few years I think of that I have but
then sometimes I start to think that I
get to like that you get a little bit
disconnected from the fun sometimes used
to feel that way yeah I think there is a
level of that like you get a little
disconnected from like the everyman like
but you don't waste as much time like
you wouldn't spend time with sit like
some drunk chick like yeah like like
just little things like that I think you
save time in okay like if someone's like
hey let's go do this and if you were
drunk you would go do it and it's just a
[ __ ] worst idea right it's when
you're sober like oh I can see that's
horrible idea yeah you know well I feel
like the the idea that the fear of not
fear of missing out but like the fear of
like it's not a fear you feel like
you're missing out on some of the fun I
feel like every comic goes to that and
maybe it's because of social media maybe
because whatever like I kept like I've
had conversation with Eric Griffin I
mean the people on this wall who when
they look through the scope of what
they're looking through their scroll to
go nom and you know look at Theo and and
it's the fighter guy you know Dustin
Poirier Oh Brendan yeah Brendan let's
you see that you go out man I've never
you know they're late they look like
they're having a good time look at them
laughing and I mean I've never been on
that like you do feel kind of like these
like left out like everyone feels that
and I think they're like that no one's
left out but everyone is feeling that
about each other and I think that's like
a stand-up comedy thing yeah I could see
that can't work together
you're a headline I'm a headliner what
are we gonna do some weird double our
show with no openers like so because I'm
watching you go have fun doing something
I'm thinking ah man I've never played
that that'd be yeah so we're forced to
kind of be like separate in these things
and then occasionally you'll see like
all of these guys together in Montreal
like why didn't go to Montreal this year
man look I'm missing out on you know
that's and then you feel it on a smaller
scale too you'll be like at Montreal you
see like - you know Chad Daniels will
walk away with you know some other comic
and you'll be like where he's gone oh we
got tickets go see Chappelle and you're
like well I didn't so this is a human
thing I think I've just feeling left out
yeah it's such a comedian thing you're
not missing anything
yeah especially with social media now
it's like there's always an
advertisement for what somebody else is
doing yeah no matter what it is so yeah
easily you could scroll scroll through
and see 70 things I'm feeling bad you
can't be at any of them yeah how could
that hotdog yeah all of that things
can't be at the you know they're out
there rotten dune cards or whatever oh I
should have been out in the mountains -
right now anyway they're doing lucky
[ __ ] you know I saw a girl I haven't
talked to in years and we never like we
just worked together on TV show it
wasn't like we weren't like together she
had a boyfriend now they're married they
have a kid I haven't talked to that girl
in easily two years we haven't worked
together waiting texts nothing I saw her
her husband they're like baby and then
another family and they like gping up in
like Joshua Tree and I felt left out on
that yeah oh they should have included
me a to cute families that are like out
night of course they didn't include why
would this but my initial brain went oh
man that I'm left out a mom that should
have been there yeah there is this whole
I think yeah I think it's just I wonder
what the long-term psychological effects
of that are of that FOMO you know that
thing where you constantly see things
that you could be doing you know that
people you know are doing and they
always appear to be joyful yeah I can
only imagine the long-term psychological
effects that aren't really good because
what are we supposed to do you can't
beat all those things yeah it's
impossible man like I'd like coach my
brain all the time like you don't have
to be jealous of these people they're
your friends you should be happy for him
relax oh yeah you know like that whole
comic thing we see someone yeah like
some like why should have that why did I
think about me why couldn't I just set a
good for that comic you know what about
this is the last thing I wanna think
about real quick is do you see I see a
lot of these commercials and it's like
let's go thank you to our first
responders thank you to our you know our
frontline workers and stuff like that
but then sometimes at a certain point
I'm seeing like even friends mom put up
videos like we took all this food to the
hospital and literally on the video you
could see the hospital is inundated with
like and they're like everyday we get
this every day and it's like and I'm not
saying it's not good I'm not saying we
shouldn't always do nice things for
other people but sometimes it just
starts to feel like whoo
what is all this it's not like it's the
military you know there's like tons of
people out on the street and you have to
half the hospitals are empty I'm like
what are they I understand if you're
buying lunch and doing something nice
for these people but most of the
frontline workers it seems like are like
post mates or people that are you know
and we thought oh that's thing this u.s.
mail I agree with that pizza pizza
delivery people like maybe not now as
much as when this first started when we
went in like real scary low-level like
people are just a mystery of not know
pizza people were like pizza delivery
guys were like saving people's life oh
yeah like the postman like that movie
the postman there's lots me with it Mike
are you Kevin Costner and the guy was
like nah dude think about actor and
they're risking their lives coming to
people's houses I mean at that time we
didn't know and they're just giving
people that have no groceries or
anything like it like that's I don't
know I think that's I think it's heroic
yeah but not now
yeah well it's sometimes it just seems
like I guess sometimes you just see
people it just seems like a a Bertot
like a thing like look at me being kind
oh I guess that's okay I guess you're
just creating kindness so I don't think
no I don't think I don't think you're
wrong it does feel weird to boast about
it like look we made a hundred of these
masks and we're gonna go dark drop them
off today it's like kind of this
braggadocious kind of look how good we
are but it's them just staying busy yeah
and also I think there's a lot of
positive but I see what you're saying
when town law is with the group and we
were in do a nice thing anymore they got
to get the credit for yeah it's tough
it's just a human thing I think that
were like that I was in Barbados one
time we had a group and we're taking
they're like let's take a day and take
toothbrushes over to this youth facility
with it were they don't have them you
know tonight so we took them over there
and the kids didn't give a [ __ ] they all
had I phones and [ __ ] we do won't give a
[ __ ] crap that's really really good then
I just felt like I guess we should have
brought iPads or something I don't know
what that's really funny
guys literally putting on a snapchat
like look at these [ __ ] dude
thinking we don't brush our tvs Buster
Posey's brought his brick
roses bra sonic cares yeah that's what I
said it on those are real piece of [ __ ]
Jeff - I thanks so much for being here
where can people check you out at man
all things at Jeff duh just the big
whirly a you know at and then Jeff duh
je FF dy yeah
were you performing next you have a spot
yet I'm doing lol comedy club in San
Antonio next nice I think next weekend I
love San Antonio yeah I'm excited it's
gonna be fun hopefully by then some of
the bars will be a little bit more open
and stuff like that that's what I'm
hoping that this is I don't know
loosening things up that's what I'm
hoping but I mean maybe not maybe we'll
go back I'm also gonna do some virtual
shows in between there just to make some
money just so I can do start working on
some stuff yeah I also have a podcast
called Jeff dies friendship podcast yeah
that's right Sean all is on all the tape
tonight Monday night don't you yeah well
usually I have a bunch back logged oh
yes which are great it's a good field um
yeah that's been really fun cuz I get to
do stuff like this like I was watching
some clear yesterday of it it's fun I'm
trying to think I can't remember what
interview it was cuz there's some people
that I could have just come hang out
with you but like if you have him for an
hour they'll sit down and say yeah like
Brian Kyle's got like a wife and kids
he's like a grown man he can't tell his
wife I'm gonna go have a beer with Jeff
died yeah she met once
but if he's like no we're gonna record a
podcast like he's a guy then now I have
an hour with Brian Kylie it really is
kind of a unique way that guys get out
of the house yeah or make friends with
people that's why I call the friendship
podcast because like you literally get
to like just say hey I admire what
you're doing
I read your book that's great you want
to come be on my pot so it's like a
productive way of having a hang yeah I
love it I love it
and I love that you had me on so thank
you all gang man thanks for coming
through Jeff da ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of my mouth I can feel it in
my bones but it's gonna take
little time for me to set that parking
brake
Oh
[Music]